you've seen how convolutions over to the
images works now let's see how you can
implement convolutions over not just to
the images but over three-dimensional
volumes
let's not serve an example let's say you
want to detect features not just in a
grayscale image but in a RGB image so an
RGB image might be instead of a six by
six image it could be six by six by
three where the three here corresponds
to the three colour channels so you
think of it as a step of three six by
six images in order to detect edges or
some other feature in this image you
convolve this not with a three by three
filter as you have previously but now
with also a 3d filter that's gonna be
three by three by three so the filter
itself will also have three layers
responding to the red green and blue
channels so to give these things some
names this first six here that's the
height at the image that's the width and
this 3 is the number of channels and
your filter also similarly has a height
width and the number of channels and the
number of channels in your image must
match the number of channels in your
filter so these two numbers have to be
equal we'll see on the next slide how
this convolution operation actually
works but the output of this will be a
four by four image and notice this is
four by four you know by one there's no
longer three at the end let's go through
in detail how this works but let's use a
more nicely drawn image so here's the
six by six by three image and here's a
three by three by three filter and this
last number the number
matches reaching the image and the
filter so to simplify the drawing of
this three by three by three filter is
sort of drawing it as a stack of three
matrices I'm also going to sometimes
it's drawn as this you know three
dimensional cube like that so to compute
the output of this convolution operation
what you would do is take the three by
three by three filter and first place it
in that upper leftmost position so
notice that this 3 by 3 by 3 filter has
27 numbers 27 parameters as T cubed and
so what you do is take each of these 27
numbers and multiply them with the
corresponding numbers from the red green
and blue channels from the image so take
the first nine numbers from red channel
then the three beneath it for the green
channel then the fee belief into the
blue Channel and multiply it with the
corresponding 27 numbers that are I
guess covered by this yellow tube shown
on the left then add up all those
numbers and this gives you this first
number in the output and then to compute
the Knicks output you take this cube and
slide it over by one and again do the
twenty-seven multiplications add up
between seven numbers that gives you
this Knicks output do it for the next
number over for the next position over
thank you the third output and so on you
know that gives you the four and then
one row down and then the next one the
next one the next one and so on
alright and you get the idea until at
the very end that's the position you
have for that final output so what does
this allow you to do well here's the
example this filter is three by three by
three so if you want to detect edges in
the red channel of the image then you
could have the first filter be one one
one
minus one minus one minus one as usual
and have a green channel be all zeros
and have the blue filter be all zeros
and if you have you know if you have
these three stack together to form your
three by three by three filter then this
would be a filter that detects edges
vertical edges but only in the red
channel or alternatively if you don't
care what color the vertical edges in
then you might have a filter just like
this whereas this one one one minus one
minus one minus one in all three
channels so by setting you know the
second alternative set of parameters you
then have an edge detector a fee by
three by three edge detector that
detects edges in you know any color and
with different choices of these
parameters you can get different feature
detectors out of this three by three by
three filter and by convention in
computer vision when you have an input
with a certain height a certain width
and a certain number of channels then
your filter will have a potential
different height different width but the
same number of channels and in theory is
possible to have a filter that maybe
only looks at the red Channel or maybe a
filter that looks at only the green
Channel and the blue Channel and once
again you notice that convolving a
volume a six by six by three
convolve with a three by three by three
that gives a four by four right to the
output now that you know how to convey
on volume does one loss idea they'll be
crucial for building convolutional
neural networks which is whether we
don't just wanted to take vertical edges
what do you want to detect vertical
edges and horizontal edges and maybe
45-degree edges and maybe seventy degree
edges as well but in other words what if
you want to use multiple filters at the
same time so here's the picture we had
from the previous line we had six
six-week involved with FIFA three or
three years four point four and maybe
this is a vertical edge detector or
maybe is learned you know to detect some
other feature now now maybe a second
filter may be denoted by this orange
color which could be a horizontal edge
detector
so maybe convolving it with the first
filter gives you this first you know
four by four output and convolving with
the second filter gives you a different
four by four output and what you can do
is then take these two four by four
outputs take this first one put it in
front and you can take the second filter
output and you draw here put in the back
as follows so that by stacking these two
together you end up with a four byte for
my two output volume right and you can
think of the volume as you grow this as
a box I guess it would maybe look like
this four by four by two output volume
which is the result of taking your six
by six line three image and convolving
it or applying to different three by
three filters to it resulting in two
four by four outputs then they get
snapped up to form a four by four by two
volume and the tomb here comes from the
fact that we use two different filters
so let's just summarize the dimensions
if you have a n by n by number of
channels input image so in the example
there's a six by six by three where n
subscript capital C is the number of
channels and you convolve that where
they F by F by and again this should be
the same NC so this was three by three
by three and by convention this and this
have to be the same number
then what you get is a n minus F plus 1
by n minus F plus 1by and then when you
use this NC Prime or really is really
and SIA the next layer but this is the
number of filters that you use so this
is in our example will be 4 by 4 by 2
and I wrote E is assuming that you use a
stride up one and no padding but did you
use a different stride or padding than
this n minus F plus 1 would be affected
in the usual way as we saw in the
previous videos so this idea of
convolution on volumes turns out to be
really powerful only a small part of it
is that you can now operate directly on
RGB images with 3 channels but even more
important is that you can now detect two
features like particular horizontal
agents or Tim or maybe 128 or maybe
several hundred different features and
the output will be then will then have a
number of channels equal to the number
of features you are detecting oh and as
a note in notation I've been using your
number of channels to denote this last
dimension in the literature people were
also often called as the depth of this
3d volume and both notations channels or
death are commonly used in the
literature but I find death more
confusing because we usually talk about
the death of a neural network as well so
I'm going to use the term channels in
these videos to refer to the size of
this 3rd dimension of these filters so
now that you know how to implement
convolutions over volumes you now are
ready to implement one layer of a
convolutional neural network let's see
how to do that in the next video